Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Sizi Ankara'nın karlı
ve soğuk havasından alacağım,
zannettiniz ki çok güzel
sıcak yerlere gideceğiz ama,
14.000 km uzaklıkta
kar ve buzlarla kaplı
Antarktika'ya götüreceğim.
Bu yolculukla ilgili,
tabii ki mesafe çok uzun,
hikâye çok uzun,
ama bu hikâyeyi,
sadece insanoğlunun
bilimsel çalışmaları yapmak adına
Antarktika'ya gitmesinden ziyade,
Dünya'nın büyük okyanusları
ve akıntısı olarak bilinen,
bizimle aynı serüveni kuzeyden
-Antarktika güneyde,
Güney Yarım Küre'de ve bir kıta-
kuzeyde,
Kuzey Deniz Buzunun donmuş hâliyle
akıntının başladığı
sisteme götürmek istiyorum.
Bu sistemden başlamamızın sebebi;
aslında gün oluyor, güneş doğuyor,
güne başlıyoruz,
öğlen oluyor, akşam oluyor,
güneş batıyor, uyuyoruz.
Ertesi gün yine uyanıyoruz.
Hiç farkına varmadığımız
günlük döngülerin,
iklim döngülerinin
bizimle hiç ilişkilendiremeyeceğiniz
deniz buzlarına işaret etmek istiyorum.
Deniz buzları,
kuzeyde Büyük Arktik Okyanusu'nun
donmuş hâli
ve baktığınızda Türkiye'nin toplamda
18 kat büyüklüğünde bir alan.
Bu alanda
-görselde de gördüğünüz gibi-
kuzeye doğru sıcak
ve yüzeydeki okyanusun suyu,
kuzeyde maviye dönüp soğuyor
ve derinleşiyor.
Bunun sebebi aslında,
bu kuzeydeki okyanusun donmuş hâli:
deniz buzları.
Yüzeydeki deniz, okyanus, donuyor.
Aslında dışarıda da kar var,
güzel örnek.
Yolların açılması için
belediye ne yapıyor yollara?
Tuz serpiyor.
Şimdi bu soğuk havayla donan
Arktik Okyanusu;
donduğu anda,
bünyesindeki tuzu saldıktan sonra,
ağırlaşarak bu ağır yükle beraber
güneye doğru seyrini yapıyor
ve bu seyir,
bizim "büyük derin akıntı"
olarak nitelendirdiğimiz seyir,
kuzeyden başlıyor
ve güneye geliyor.
Güneye geldiği anda,
normalde bu sistemin tabii ki
kuzeyden başladı,
güneye geldi derken,
çok kolay bir yol da katetmiyor.
Deniz yüzeyindeki bütün besinleri
deniz dibine taşıyor,
canlıların beslenmesini sağlıyor.
Kendi içinde büyük bir akıntı varken,
aynı zamanda küçük girdapların
oluştuğu bölgeler de mevcut.
Bunu bilimsel yayınlardan
çok rahat, net bir şekilde
-gözle göremesek bile-
net bir şekilde biliyoruz.
Aslında baktığınız zaman
bu bir kapalı devre.
Kuzeye sıcak olarak çıkan okyanus suları,
soğuyarak güneye iniyor,
güneydeki Anktartika'nın etrafındaki
Güney Okyanusu'nun
yine soğukluğuyla
ve tuzluluğuyla besleniyor
ve bu tuzlulukla beraber ekvatora
geldikten sonra ısınarak kuzeye çıkıyor.
Kapalı bir devre.
Okyanusların, aslında
bu büyük akıntıdaki
veya insanoğluna olan etkisi,
iklim sistemini stabilize etmesi.
Okyanuslar
aslında baktığınızda,
%50 karbondioksiti
bünyesinde barındırır.
Aynı zamanda, dünya yüzeyindeki
ısının da %75'ini barındırır.
Bu sebeple soğuk atmosferin,
okyanus akıntısı devam ederken
atmosfere verdiği ısıyla
aslında bizim iklimlerimiz oluşur.
Bu sayede,
bu okyanus akıntısı sayesinde
biz yazı, kışı, mevsimleri,
sonbaharı, ilkbaharı yaşarız.
Ama son dönemlerde,
özellikle yapılmış bilimsel yayınlarda
biz bu sistemin yavaşladığını görüyoruz.
Bu yavaşlama sebebinde de,
aslında buzların tanımı devreye giriyor.
Buzlar eriyor, evet.
Haberlerde, televizyonlarda,
yayınlarda sürekli duyuyoruz.
Hangi buzlar eriyor peki?
Kaç buz olabilir ki?
Buzlar, aslında bizim kuzeyde
ve güneyde iki gruba ayırıyoruz:
Bir kara üzerinde,
kara yapısının üzerinde oluşan buzlar.
Bir de
deniz yüzeyinin üzerinde oluşan buzlar.
Deniz yüzeyinin üzerinde oluştu mu
oluşurken oluşumunu tamamlar,
ama eridiğinde
deniz suyu seviyesini arttırmaz.
Karadan oluşmuş buzların erimesiyle,
dışarıdan girdilerle
deniz suyu seviyesi artar.
Şimdi deniz buzu ve karasal buzu
ikiye ayırdıktan sonra,
bu deniz suyu seviyesine baktığımızda
ve buzların erimesine baktığımızda,
duyduğumuz
-kuzeydeki özellikle-
yaklaşık 3-4 milyon kilometre kare kadar
bir deniz buzunun
eridiğinden bahsediyoruz.
Eğer bu yayınlar;
bu sistemin, iklim sistemini
dengede tutan akıntı sisteminin
yavaşladığına yönelik yayınlar varsa,
sebebi azalan miktardaki deniz buzları.
Deniz buzları donacak ki,
tuzu bünyesinde barındırmayacak.
Salınan deniz tuzlarıyla birlikte
bu akıntılar,
bu kapalı devre serüvenini tamamlayacak.
Aslında deniz buzu,
bizim yaşamımızda fark etmesek de
çok büyük öneme sahip.
Aslında iklimimizin dengesini
ortaya koyuyor.
%75 bu ısıyı akıntılar;
yukarıdan aşağıya,
kuzeyden güneye,
güneyden ekvatora,
ekvatordan tekrar
kuzeye taşırken de bu ısıların,
soğuk atmosferle dengesini,
kurgusunu yapıyor.
Baktığımızda
sadece bu akıntının yavaşlaması değil,
deniz buzunun oluşumuyla beraber
ortaya çıkan akıntıların taşıdığı
besinlerde de azalmalar oluyor.
Bu besinlerde azalmalar yaşandığında;
-mercanlar gibi-
denizlerde, okyanuslardaki yapıların
etkilendiğini görüyoruz.
Nasıl etkileniyorlar?
%90 derecede kayıp alanları oluşuyor,
kırmızı alanlar.
Daha az miktarda kayıplara
sebebiyet veren turuncu alanlar
ve daha etkilenmeden
başlamamış yeşil alanlarımız var,
ama gördüğünüz gibi,
okyanusların
bu etkilenmesinden kaynaklanan
-ister kuzey olsun, ister güney olsun-
bütün dünyanın
etkisi altına aldığı bu değişimden
nasibini bütün canlılar alıyor.
Tabii ki bu akıntılar
bizi kuzeyden güneye,
Antarktika'ya taşıyor.
Antarktika dediğimizde;
güneye, Güney Kutbu'na iniyoruz
ve Güney Kutbu'nda,
dünyanın 5. kıtası olarak adlandırdığımız
Antartika kıtasına bakıyoruz.
Etrafında Güney Okyanusu çevrili,
Güney Okyanusu da yine bu akıntı sistemini
besleyen sistemin ta kendisi.
Buradaki buzlara ne oluyor?
Buradaki buzlar da
değişip beslenmeyi durdurursa,
acaba bu akıntı sistemi
komple mi durur?
Aslında bazı senaryolar var,
bilimsel senaryolar var.
Kötü senaryolara göre,
çok da dillendirmek istemediğimiz
2100 yılına kadar
deniz buzlarının tamamıyla
yok olmasıyla beraber,
bu sistemin yavaşlamadan ziyade,
tamamıyla yok olacağıyla ilgili.
Ama bilim insanları çalışıyor.
Hem kuzeyde, hem güneyde
bilim insanları
özellikle geçmişe ışık tutmak,
geçmişteki bilimsel verileri topladıktan
sonra günümüzde neler oluyor
ve geçmişle günü birleştirdiğimizde,
"Gelecekte bizi neler bekliyor?"u
ortaya koyuyor.
Biz de Türkiye olarak,
Antartika'ya üç senedir
seferler düzenliyoruz.
Hedefimiz burada jeoloji çalışmaları,
buzul çalışmaları,
iklim çalışmaları,
denizel alanlardaki çalışmalar,
deniz bilimleri çalışmalarını icra etmek
ve özellikle bu iklim değişimiyle ilgili
gelmiş olduğumuz noktada
nasıl bir etki gözlemleniyor
ortaya koymak.
Türk bilim insanlarının yapmaya başladığı
ve çalışmaya başladığı
Antarktika alanıyla ilgili,
özellikle ortaya konulacak veriler
çok önemli.
İklim değişiminin neresindeyiz?
İklim daha önce nasıldı?
Bu sadece deniz buzları
ve karasal buzlardan da ziyade,
buzların içinde hapsolmuş
karbondioksit miktarına kadar
bilim insanları bakabiliyor.
Karbondioksit miktarını günlük olarak,
şu an internet ortamından
çok net olarak görebiliyoruz.
Dün baktığımda
409 değerine denk gelen
karbondioksit birim miktarı,
aslında bilim insanlarının
Antarktika'dan çıkardığı
buzların içinden ortaya koyarak
laboratuvar ortamında ölçtüğünde,
280 birimine denk geliyordu.
Sera gazları dediğimizde,
atmosferdeki bu birikmiş sera gazlarının
en önemlilerinden ve en yüksek seviyede
olanlarından olan karbondioksit,
özellikle günümüzde
geldiği nokta tehlikeli.
Çünkü karbondioksiti,
ben genelde karbondioksit
atmosferde birikme oranını
"battaniye" olarak değerlendiriyorum.
Üşüdüğümüzde üstümüze battaniye alırız,
kalın kıyafet giyeriz.
Neden?
Çünkü insanın bedeninin ısısını
içeride hapsedip
bu ısının kaçmasını engellemek isteriz.
Karbondioksit battaniyesi de öyle bir şey.
Dünyanın atmosferde biriken,
bu özellikle antropojenik dediğimiz
insan kaynaklı karbondioksit yapılarının,
atmosferde birim miktarının 200'lerden,
şu an 400'ü aşkın seviyeye gelmiş olması
battaniyenin kalınlığının
arttığını gösterir
ve Güneş'in
Dünya'ya gelen ışınları da
gelirken şiddetli,
ama çıkarken belirli derecede
absorbe oluyor
ve devamında tekrar yansıyıp
atmosferden çıkması gerekirken,
battaniye tabakasına hapsolup
yeryüzüyle battaniye arasında
sıkışmış bir şekilde,
yeryüzünün ısısının değişmesine
ve artmasına sebep oluyor.
Bu sebeple
bilim insanlarının
yapmış olduğu çalışmalar,
ortaya koyacakları bulgular
çok önem arz etmekte.
Deniz buzu dediğimiz,
karasal buzul dediğimiz
ya da diğer her türlü
-canlılar da dahil olmak üzere-
sistemin içinde etkilenen
her bir parametrenin,
nereden nereye geldiğini çalışmak
gerçekten önemli.
Antarktika'ya ve Arktik'e
gittiğiniz noktalar uzak,
bu uzak noktalarda
topladığınız veriler önemli.
İklim sistemine açıklık getirirken
bu iklim sisteminde,
kapalı devre sisteme
tekrar dikkat çekmek istiyorum.
Kuzeydeki mavi ve yoğun,
ağır akıntının
güneyde Antarktika'da beslenmesi,
Antarktika'da beslentikten sonra
yine etrafında oluşmuş
deniz buzlarıyla beslendikten sonra
ekvatora çıkıp ısınarak
kuzeyde seyahatini tamamlaması 1000 yıl.
Bu 1000 yıllık serüvende,
ortadan yok olmuş
deniz buzları miktarları yüzünden
bu sistem yavaşladı.
Yavaşladı demek
iklim sistemimize farklı şekilde
etkileyecek demek ki,
bu yüzdendir daha önce yaşamadığımız
her türlü doğal felaketleri yaşamaktayız.
Aslında burada çıkış yok görünüyor.
Kapalı devre bir sistem.
Sistemin başında,
deniz buzlarından başlayan
serüvenle azalan noktadaki
kuzeydeki buzların etkisiyle,
gelinen noktada sistemin yavaşladığına
dikkat çekiyor bilim insanları.
Ama çözüm var.
Bu çözüm bizlerde.
Bu sistemi yavaşlatan da biziz,
bunun devamını sağlayacak olan da biziz.
Net bir şekilde iklim değişimine
inananlar var mı demek istedim,
sonra vazgeçtim,
çünkü bilim camiası içinde bile
hâlâ büyük bir tartışma söz konusu.
Gerçek mi, değil mi?
%90 bilim insanı,
iklim değişimini bilimsel olarak da
ortaya koymuş durumda.
%10,
bunun Dünya'nın genel bir sirkülasyonu
olduğunu düşünmekte.
Rakam büyük.
İnanan bilim insanlarının,
ortaya koyan bilim insanlarının
rakamları büyük.
Ama ister istemez,
bizlerin de birey olarak
özellikle insan kaynaklı gelmiş olduğumuz
ve yaratmış olduğumuz
iklim değişimi ile ilgili,
çözümler basit ve çok basit.
Yenilenebilir enerjinin,
özellikle ağaçların, bitkilerin,
doğanın dengesinin devam etmesi,
enerjinin daha kullanılabilir hâle
gelmesini sağlamak bizler için önemli.
Geri dönüşüm.
Geri dönüşüm; kullandığımız her şeylerin
mümkün olan her şeyin,
geri dönüşü çok önemli.
Aslında çıkış yolu sizsiniz,
aslında çıkış yolu biziz.
Gelmiş olduğumuz noktada,
sistemi geri çevirecek bireyler biziz.
Çıkış sizsiniz.
Teşekkürler.
(Alkış)